j'ai un truc super intéressant vous
présenter aujourd'hui c'est un produit
JBL un truc que vous ne connaissez pas
c'est une première mondiale le truc qui
est assez dingue et je suis très heureux
parce que je suis un des premiers des
premiers chanceux à vous le présenter
c'est un produit qui sortira l'année
prochaine et ce produit si tu juste ici
vous êtes prêts vous êtes prêts on y va
[Musique]
ça s'appelle les tours de tour 2 tour de
s'intéresse en fait je vous explique le
truc vous avez vos écouteurs vous
connaissez le principe des écouteurs le
principe des intra vous les prenez vous
les mettez dans vos oreilles mais il y a
toujours un petit accessoire qui est
très sympa et qu'on sous-estime et qui
souvent n'est pas trop utilisé
collective vous voyez ce que les
directement à mon smartphone et bien
c'est l'étui de recharge l'étui de
recharge ici il est révolutionnaire on
peut le dire pourquoi parce que vous
avez un écran dessus avant me direz
qu'est-ce que je vais faire dans l'écran
sur mon étude recharge tu peux pas
regarder la télé non je vais pas
regarder l'école des fans non j'ai pas
regardé monsieur au-dessus non il faut
faire pendant des heures non ce que vous
allez faire ici vous avez plein de
paramètres qui vous permettront de venir
régler vos écouteurs moduler le son
régler la réduction de bruit active
l'activer la désactiver le volume
l'équaliseur bref beaucoup de choses que
vous allez venir régler ici ça c'est la
première fois qu'on le voit parce que on
le sait quand on a un smartphone
fatalement on vient tout faire avec son
smartphone si on a une montre connectée
et qui il y a une application et qu'on
peut venir tout régler avec sa montre
connectée c'est extrêmement pratique
mais si vous n'avez pas de smartphone
vous l'avez pas sous la main et si vous
n'avez pas de montre connectée et bien
il vous manque un truc si par exemple
vous avez vos écouteurs et que vous les
connectez directement à un PC avec votre
étui vous pouvez venir tout moduler très
facilement je trouve ça vachement bien
je vais vous montrer vous allez pas être
au bout de vos surprises et commencez à
réfléchir parce que ça ça arrivera en
2023 et ça va changer les choses vous me
direz ça sert à quoi d'avoir un truc
comme ça déjà vous montrer ce qu'on peut
venir faire avec vous allez voir toi qui
vachement intéressant alors vous avez
différents modes donc là vous lancez
votre musique vous l'arrêtez le truc qui
aurait été intéressant c'est qu'on vient
de récupérer mais peut-être que JBL le
mettre à plus tard qu'on vient de
récupérer les informations du morceau
c'est le seul truc qui aurait été cool
effectivement c'est de le voir ici
pourquoi pas récupérer la pochette
ensuite ce que j'ai ici c'est mon volume
vient monter le son je viens baisser le
son ça c'est pratique là j'ai tout mon
côté réduction bruit avec la réduction
de proactive la NC active night and
selling je peux avoir l'ambiance song
donc je viens tout changer d'ici très
très facilement le truc que j'aime bien
ça se trouve que l'écran est réactif
vous voyez c'est quand même pas mal
réactif alors faut bien se positionner
en face on s'en doutera parce que c'est
pas extrêmement grand moi j'ai pas des
très grands doigts j'imagine que vous
pensez qu'on est très grands doigts
peut-être est-ce qu'ils vont galérer un
peu plus là votre équaliseur alors là ce
qui est très cool c'est que vous avez
plein de mods alors regardez club basse
VO jazz custom ça vous venez de
paramétrer directement dans votre
application studio et on a fait le tour
c'est quand même plutôt pas mal aussi là
vous avez hop un petit timer vous pouvez
venir moduler vous montez jusqu'à 60
minutes regardez si je vais ici 60
minutes je peux l'activer ensuite le son
spatialisé qui est aussi très très cool
et qu'on a ici avec trois options au
niveau de mon son spatialisé le Voice
aware c'est lorsque je viens parler qui
vient reconnaître ma voix vous voyez
donc je vais soit l'avoir en mide soit
en a et soit en lot ensuite un silent
now ok why not un auto play post que je
peux venir activer et désactiver très
facilement donc cet écran en fait il est
assez malin et après on revient au début
point positif c'est que l'écran il est
lumineux là on est en extérieur
quasiment en extérieur on voit bien on
voit très très bien ça c'est plutôt cool
vous avez aussi tous vos indicateurs de
batterie pour votre étui écouteur gauche
écoute en droit vous voyez si vous êtes
connecté si vous voyez j'ai un petit
point d'exclamation lorsque je viens
l'ouvrir voyez là il est connecté à mon
smartphone je le vois j'ai l'heure
également donc l'idée de cet écran je
trouve ça extrêmement malin les
écouteurs je trouve aussi assez joli
c'est un peu plat ici sur le côté plutôt
by designer donc ça c'est vrai que c'est
plutôt sympa aussi
je vous le donne à chaud je vous dis ce
que je pense de ces tours Pro 2 alors
au-delà du côté qualité audio de JBL
au-delà de la réduction de bruit active
que j'ai pas pu tester parce que autant
je les ai écoutés j'ai trouvé bien mais
pour les tester il faudrait laisser un
peu plus de temps donc aujourd'hui je
donne pas mon retour sur le produit mais
je vous donne mon retour sur l'idée sur
le concept et le fait de venir mettre un
écran ici sur un étui de charge de ses
écouteurs et je trouve ça extrêmement
malin mais vraiment vraiment c'est pas
un côté gadget vous savez je me suis
posé la question quant à la commencer à
faire cette vidéo quand on est venu ici
à Amsterdam chez JBL chez Harman je me
suis dit est-ce que le truc est pas
gadget est-ce que ça sert à quelque
chose réellement de revenir mettre en
écran ici puis après on mouline dans la
tête on se dit ok là je suis là j'ai mon
téléphone alors pour autant j'ai pas
regardé ça dans ma main vous voyez mais
si je suis sur le bureau je peux le
poser là le téléphone est là si je mets
play pause je peux le faire si par
exemple je reçois un appel et bien je
peux venir décrocher aussi directement
en même temps je trouve ça cool je
trouve ça malin alors après il y a des
limites il y a des choses qui sont pas
encore développées parce que on en est
dans une prévention il faut savoir que
ça les équipes de JBL m'ont expliqué que
là tout de suite on tourne on est au
mois d'octobre la production de masse va
commencer au mois le novembre donc pour
l'instant on est vraiment sur les
premiers produits on n'est pas du tout
sur la production de masse et c'est un
produit qui arrivera dans les magasins
en début d'année prochaine début 2023
donc vous voyez même la boîte que j'ai
là elle est susceptibles d'évoluer alors
on va voir les mêmes couleurs c'est les
codes de JBL donc on voit que on est
vraiment tout au début et c'est génial
de pouvoir avoir un produit comme ça en
avance de phase réellement pour pouvoir
donner un retour donc une fois de plus
je vous ai montré où j'ai Lecture pause
et bien je voudrais avoir les
informations du morceau de la même
manière que je l'ai sur ma montre
connectée je voudrais avoir les
informations par exemple de Spotify
remonter mes playlists il y a ses petits
affichages aujourd'hui qui n'existent
pas qui peut-être existeront au moment
où le produit sera disponible dans le
commerce et mais peut-être après ça
continuera à évoluer donc l'idée elle
est vachement cool je vous le dis une
fois de plus avec pour un smartphone on
se dit ouais j'ai un smartphone j'ai la
Watch mais projetez-vous en se disant si
je le connecte à un PC et bien je l'ai
pas donc ça en fait c'est une petite
télécommande sans fil je trouve ça malin
et une fois de plus ça reste dans un
tarif qui est quand même maîtrisé par
rapport à ce qu'on retrouve sur le
marché pour des écouteurs haut de gamme
avec une réduction de bruit active avec
de la RS alors ici nous annonce jusqu'à
40 heures au niveau de l'écoute 10
heures par écouteur et jusqu'à 30 heures
avec le boîtier de rechargement alors
j'imagine que c'est réduction de bruit
coupé donc jusqu'à mais en tout cas
c'est là et c'est cool alors après
vouloir qu'un son spatialisé six micro
pour des appels de qualité on a en plus
du Bluetooth le ça c'est très très cool
on a la réduction de bruit active on a
le Smart ambiance ah oui on va jusqu'à
24 heures avec la réduction de bruit
active jusqu'à 30 heures sans réduction
de bruit active et en 15 minutes de
charge pour partez pour 4h je vous le
dis c'est écrit ici je l'ai pas pris par
cœur c'est de l'xp X5 on a du Fast pair
avec Google on peut utiliser bien
évidemment sur iOS mais également sur
Android on a Google Alexa on a Google
Alexa on a Google assistant on a Amazon
Alexa bref on a tout le savoir-faire de
JBL dans des écouteurs avec un truc qui
est réellement très intéressant et
révolutionnaire c'est le fait de venir
mettre un petit écran ici peut-être que
l'usage ne sera pas fait pour vous
peut-être vous direz-vous moi j'en ai
pas besoin de ce gadget mais je pense
que une fois qu'on y a goûté et bien on
est très heureux d'avoir son petit
raccourci parce que même si vous avez
votre smartphone même si vous avez votre
Spotify et bien si vous voulez venir
moduler votre réduction de bruit active
si vous voulez venir moduler plein de
choses des petites options que vous
n'avez que dans l'application les
qualithers typiquement et bien là je
vais pouvoir venir moduler votre
équaliseur ici si vous écoutez un
morceau de jazz et vous écoutez du
hip-hop vous voulez pas forcément le
même équaliseur et bien là vous l'avez
directement sous la main vous venez de
moduler alors bien évidemment il y a des
choses que je vous dis une fois de plus
on fera sur le smartphone mais grâce à
ça vous pouvez aller un peu plus en
profondeur dans les réglages fin de vous
écouter et c'est en ça que je trouve ça
malin alors je donne la référence
regardez là vraiment dans un coin de
votre tête ou sur un bout de papier pour
l'année prochaine sont les JBL tour Pro
2 les écouteurs sont cools les écouteurs
se positionnent très facilement l'audio
et de qualité une fois de plus faudrait
vraiment que je ne teste plus longuement
parce que là c'est vraiment une première
prise en main et une première découverte
vous voyez ça fit c'est cool c'est bien
donc on en reparlera probablement
d'ailleurs dites-moi ça vous intéresse
en bas dans les commentaires et puis
c'est chouette voyez on est à Amsterdam
on dirait pas qu'on a Amsterdam on m'a
dit Aurel quand tu vas venir à Amsterdam
tu verras il y a de la pluie tu disais
ça coco ou pas tu m'as dit à chaque fois
que je viens il y a de la pluie vrai ou
pas et là il y a de la pluie ou pas non
voilà il y a grand soleil donc on va
aller se balader on va de découvrir je
ne connais pas cette ville et c'est très
chouette voilà donc prenez soin de vous
je vous embrasse si vous avez des
questions des interrogations des
suggestions sur ce produit allez-y juste
en bas dans les commentaires je suis sûr
que JBL quasiment sûr ce sont les JBL
tour Pro 2 voilà prenez soin de vous
bisous à bientôt moi j'ai une maladie
Ciao
[Musique]